salmon the sort of limited time we have
left I know we're getting to the end
here I did want to base with you about
white supremacy a little bit and and
manifestos because I was I took some
criticism years ago when I said a an
Islamic terrorist or perpetrator who
states that their motivations were
related to Islam should be considered
genuine and serious and while there may
be other aggravating factors which we
can talk about that that needs to be
taken seriously and I believe that and
in the same way when I hear about you
know a perpetrator that is apparently a
white supremacist who was participating
in all of the known places on the
Internet which I don't even need to name
and there's no point in naming them and
they say that these were motivating
factors I believe unless I have a really
specific reason to think otherwise I
also believe that they're genuine and
I've seen that you've talked about the
idea of those right-wing shooters
sometimes in your opinion writing a semi
bogus manifesto maybe to confuse the
media maybe to get attention and I I
definitely don't see it that way absent
some evidence that would change my mind
so I'm curious how you came to that
conclusion you know it was just based on
hearing some evidence or alleged
evidence in that area and I'm actually
my next podcast is gonna be with
Kathleen below there's a a you know
historian on this topic of white
supremacy so I'll sort of dive deeper
into that and get a little more of an
education there but yeah I mean the the
issue seems to be that there's this this
other variant of you know troll culture
that is attracting in many cases
mentally unstable
isolated you know socially isolated
young men some percentage of whom are
just be kind of viewing opportunities
for violence as a kind of video game and
this gets mixed in with you know some
level of racism or white supremacy or
misogyny
or all of those things and it's not
clear you know what really is the
motivating factor I mean said and again
some in some cases violence is over
determined right so you have someone who
is is mentally ill but is also enamored
of some some bad you know violence
producing ideas and may also have a
legitimate grievance in the world right
and then that person goes into a
synagogue or a mosque or or a school and
kills people and then we're left trying
to sort out what was really the
operating variables but they're they're
pure cases right of all of these things
to where it's just you have
psychologically normal people who are
motivated clearly by ideas and they
state those ideas and there's no reason
to doubt them right and so there are
clear cases of every type I think it's
it's far more common to have socially
socially marginalized psychologically
unwell people go in and shoot up schools
and I think it's also far more common to
have people fitting that type join white
supremacist organizations than it is to
have those variables be the explanation
for jihadism may I judge you the reason
why I think jihadism is different then
and I did a solo podcast on this topic
differentiate differentiating jihadism
from white supremacy I think it is it's
an important lead if ur n't set of ideas
and most important in a different
context right it's it jihadism is a is
an extremist set of ideas set within a
mainstream religion and disentangling
those ideas from the the mainstream
religious ideas that people truly care
about that you know more than a billion
people truly care about is genuinely
difficult right and entails theological
hair-splitting that is frankly not very
convincing right so it's a hard problem
and it's for this that for that reason
attracting far more you know
straightforwardly religious normal
people into its ranks white supremacy is
not quite the same right it's not it
doesn't have it has links to
Christianity but the links are not as
direct and they're not as not as broad
and they're not as connected to other
things that are good about Christianity
right the things that people normal
people really want about Christianity
and so I think it is filtering for you
know unbalanced
more deranged people more marginal
people people who have less opportunity
and and more grievances or pseudo
grievances but then there are cases
where you know the violence is coming
from you know just psychopathy or or
other psychopathology right we're we're
then then whatever lip service may or
may not be paid to ideas it really is
just lip service it's not really the
ideas and you don't know until you you
know but another point as an example
like um I think that the Columbine
shooting is often talked about in the
context of these you know you know
online discussions of white supremacist
violence and I think Eric Harris in his
journals wrote a fair amount about you
know white supremacy but you know one
who's really looked at the details of
the Columbine shooting thinks that this
is a a clear case of white supremacist
violence I mean these were really
disturbed young men who decided to kill
their classmates and you know it's that
this was not the Oklahoma City bombing
which is which was clearly ideological
and so it's just you just don't know
until you know and when I spoke about
the El Paso shooting and even the Christ
Christ Church shooting it just wasn't
totally clear to me what was what in
terms of those manifestos